[Music]
this is a real news story that
Kardashians came out with their
Christmas card yesterday and I guess
they come out with it every year and
this year they came out with a
particularly unusual one it's very
artistic and it has a lot of and this we
got one right here this is this is it we
didn't make this up or anything
this is the Kardashian Christmas card
Wow
and everyone's talking about it because
of the weird imagery and symbolism and
you notice that it Kinkos no no there's
cam over here you can see Kim is there
standing on a stairway and Bruce Jenner
is in a tube and no one knows why
[Laughter]
Bruce enters in a tube and no one gets
why and there's lots of little like
Easter eggs in there there's a Wheaties
box for some yeah there's a Wheaties box
over there in the freezer
yeah with Bruce Jenner on it there's a
Kanye Magazine cover that's lying in a
pile on the floor and anyway it's packed
with all these little surprises and then
biggest surprise of all you fold it
together at the end and it spells out
[Applause]
some pity message really at the light
yeah fantastic tonight I don't know I'm
gonna have to change my Christmas cards
because mine said that I suck look like
I'm ripping them off your says that
every year